the ardèche region in Southeast France a
refuge for vacationers seeking to
replenish body and soul on market days
these stands sell everything the land
has to offer local goat cheeses and
salami are especially prized
agritourism is popular to the farmer is
your host and personal chef Phillipe and
Veronique occurred from the village of
Hosea grow vegetables and herbs she
tends the garden he runs the kitchen
only 20 p this event we're in the
foothills of the Savannah all wanted it
for generations people have built stone
walls and cultivated the land that's why
the soil here is very deep and soft and
easy to work akeefa sealer facility on
TV filipa card is not a trained chef he
gained his extensive knowledge of herbs
through long experience the premiere
buzzy week sunday but first we have
cinnamon basil him probably it's very
peppery and adds power to dishes the
forks of the donut blow oh sweet then we
have a nice basil remorse a basil which
also tastes a little like a nice you
gotta Melanie's your puter positive and
then we have purple basil which has that
classic basil flavor and lens extra
color to the dish when you will do duplo
most of the flowers in the garden also
find culinary use Philippe belongs to an
association of cooks in a dish who make
a point of bringing the region's
dazzling variety of flavors to a wider
audience
one of his favorite dishes is bagua a
vegetable composition based on
artichokes those who wish can add bacon
first saute onions in the bacon add salt
sugar and some water
citroen nuclear song angra Sasha don't
with the sugar the liquid becomes
thicker until it's a glaze for the
vegetables because implement the rule
that high sins and underscores the
flavor of each vegetables we near a
wooded Oh shucks regular season with
pepper cardamom and fenugreek seeds then
it's the artichokes turn break off the
stem and remove the leaves so that only
the artichokes heart remains immerse in
water with lemon juice so they don't
turn brown but the chef uses the stems
to do de sevilla stems have just as much
aroma as the hearts then slice a fennel
bulb and put it in the pot
in a separate pan glaze the carrots in
oil water salt sugar vanilla and
cinnamon
baby turnips aren't given some heat from
cumin and anis an orifice frivolity
grima decrease on dande recipe on the
field I often use a separate pan for
each vegetable because I want their
flavors to blend only once the guest is
enjoying them shekou kirito a semi-rigid
on LaLoosh as a finish add the peas when
it comes time to serve there's a strict
sequence to follow the artichokes and
fennel come onto the plate first then
the carrots and turnips then he adds the
raw ingredients red beets zucchini and
radishes the composition is garnished
with herbs and blossoms from the garden
as addressing Philippe I cut blends the
cooking liquid with oil and soy lecithin
instead of an egg the vegetable dish can
be eaten warm or cold and as always the
owners join their guests at the table